[indistinct chatter on radio]
Buenos noches, Pedro.
- Hi, Terry.
- 'Hey, Terry.'
Whoo-whoo!
(Jones)
'You wanna know why we're here?'
Why, is there a fight?
- No, there's not a fight yet.
- Yeah, they...
Terry we got a call that, uh
'somebody, an employee here'
'was turnin' tricks
up on the roof.'
- No way.
- Yeah.
- Yes way.
- Yeah way.
That's no, not cool.
- Well, what's not cool...
- You know anything about that?
- You know anything about it?
- No.
I'm afraid of roofs,
so it wasn't me.
I'm allergic to 'em.
- You're allergic to roofs?
- I'm allergic to roofs.
- Uh-huh.
- 'You can ask my doctor.'
How does that manifest itself?
How are you allergic to roofs?
If look at them, I throw up.
You know what I'm allergic to?
Lies.
We had a description about a
gentleman of your height
your stature,
with a little hat.
What did they have...
What was the person's name?
Well, I guess,
you know, it might rhyme
with Mary or Harry.
My name isn't Mary or Harry.
My name is...
♪ Terry ♪♪
- Well, hold on, Terry.
- What?
There's something
I wanna say, okay?
- What?
- Listen. You know what?
You're misunderstood, okay?
- I'm totally misunderstood.
- You-You're misunderstood.
And, um, I wanted to know
what if you and I were to...
...go up on the roof?
How much would you...
...would you...
I mean, how much would it be?
For...
[whispering]
For what?
If I wanted to get
like a little bit of...
...[bleep].
How much would it be?
[grunts]
[whispering]
Five dollars.
- Terry, I'm a cop.
- What?
I'm holding your hand.
And I'm, I'm a cop--
- I said $5 for the taco.
- You, you just...
You just solicited a sexual ass
[bleep], you know.
Ouch. What are you guys doing?
Tacos, tacos, tacos, tacos
is self-served tonight
ladies and gentlemen.
Sorry about that, Pedro.
Call the police. I'm being
arrested by the police.